[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo what's going on everybody shout outs
to everyone joining me
live here this saturday on the cg live
livestream welcome
welcome everyone um so today
we are continuing the art
um continuing our submissions for the
alternate reality cg challenge if you
guys don't know what it is at this point
you know um welcome to the channel i've
issued
y'all basically a uh an animation
and in this animation i'm asking you
guys to replace the character and
replace the environment and just have a
blast with it
you just can't touch the camera you
can't touch the characters like
you know animation body position kind of
stuff um
and yeah you just fill it out and do
some cool stuff we have 122 submissions
so far
and yeah i've been working on mine for
the last two weeks or so
you guys been doing the same and we're
just gonna we're gonna hop into it let
me let me switch over here
what's going on everybody welcome
welcome welcome today
ah it's good to see you guys um
yeah yeah i've been i've been working on
my
my art this week i spent all of
wednesday like the entirety of wednesday
probably 12 plus hours
just working on this trying to get this
sewer system looking correct
um so i want to talk to you guys about
how i did that and how i created this
like
endless looking texture um i went
outside i took a bunch of pictures
processed them and kind of turned it
into a really cool looking
uh sewer here so i want to show you guys
how exactly
i accomplished that um
and how powerful that is for basically
anything you want you can create any
texture you want
obviously you can see here that like
certain parts are more uh more
reflective and more rough
and i'll show you guys how to process
all these textures and stuff in
photoshop
it's really fun very simple in a very
satisfying
process that if you guys hadn't created
your own textures before
it's gonna be really cool um so let's uh
let's hide the fog so we can get a
little bit more render quality on this
you guys also can see i have this giant
like
dirt pit which right now currently in
the render as is is not really selling
and i need to i just need to do a better
job of i don't know
framing it or i don't know it's gonna be
a tough one it's gonna be a tough one i
have to figure out how that's exactly
gonna go
but yeah right now we're gonna focus on
just this sewer system i'm gonna show
you guys how i made these
custom textures and um there's no
looping here it's just like
really a really long image
that just it just goes um
and this is the short version of it too
it's pretty insane
um yeah so i'll show you guys how to
make those textures
and then i'm just going to detail the
crap out of this sewer system i'm going
to put a bunch of junk in the corners
i'm going to put a bunch of like uh
shrubs and plants here building up in
the center where the water is
based off of reference imagery i took
and
really just trying to work out my
foreground here we got a couple missing
textures i have to relink here
but yeah how are you guys doing how's
everyone doing today thanks for
hopping in the stream welcome happy
saturday to everyone
i hope you guys are having a good time
oh got some peppermint tea very nice i
went rock climbing yesterday
um it was it was
it was difficult it was very difficult i
learned how to tie anchors
which is like a very a very
i don't say stressful process but it's
like um
i don't know if you get the anchors
wrong
you will die so you better not mess up
your knots and you better not mess up
the position
of your carabiners and all that stuff um
so it was really cool my buddy jan
taught me how to do all that stuff
and we climbed some really tall rocks
freaking awesome so i am very sore today
i am extremely sore but it was
so worth it it's really nice to get
outside and climb some rocks man it
feels good it feels really good
yeah um so
how did i create this endless texture
let me show you guys
this endless texture if we get in close
here we can see that it's
pretty darn detailed
right and i actually just
well here's here's here's exactly what
happened here's exactly
how i did this so
there is a place um
that i will not mention
because you all have to find your own
wall here
but there's a place i went to um
somewhere in los angeles oh
i can tell it's a little stretched i
might have to stretch that back there
um yeah there's a place i went to in los
angeles it's essentially
you know like the la river i basically
found a spot somewhere in the la river
that had
vertical 90 degree walls just like this
and what i did was basically went into
this
you know i don't i don't know the
technical name for this kind of like
wash or la river i don't know it's
definitely not a river
it's like an overflow thing from the
mountains to the ocean
uh i don't know exactly what that's
called
but i went through with my iphone and i
just took pictures making sure that each
image
overlapped a little bit so like if i
were to take a shot here
with this like yellow let's say i took a
shot here with the yellow piece on the
left side
i would move over and take a shot here
so that yellow piece
is in both of the pictures and i just
you know kept going
kept going so i'm looking at this streak
or this streak here on the left
move over yep there's that streak on the
right now
so you just want to keep going and keep
shooting these images
with a little bit of overlap and
what i did let me open up lightroom
because what i did is i took all those
images from
my iphone let's see here
let me yeah here we go here we go
all right one moment
all right
a ravine a waterway something like that
yeah something like that
you know i took all these pictures just
going from
let's see let me get rid of this second
window
screen mode normal
yeah i just kept going through taking
pictures and
the original image i believe
if i were to take off the crop looks a
little
something like this um i also
adjusted like the transform values and i
adjusted
the camera calibration let's see the
transform values
and the lens correction so since i shot
on an iphone
i enabled the lens correction you know
remove chromatic aberration
and i chose the apple profile and it
removes the
basically like the distortion that you
get from on you know from shooting on
your iphone
and then i went through and i actually
let's see if i can get rid of this crop
for a second um as shot yes please
so i went through and i took this
transform value and i basically
straightened out my edges
all right since it's a wall you know i
want to be able to
make sure it's as uh perpendicular and
parallel and 90 degrees as possible
so let's see if i can't reset this
so that's off and this is on and what
i'm doing is going through and i'm
adding these
little like these little rulers
essentially or these guides
and i'm saying i'm drawing a line from
this side to this side
and maybe i can just delete see if i
can't delete these guys
and do it with you and show you how i'm
doing this
so basically i took a picture of my wall
to turn this into a 3d texture
i just want to straighten it out a
little bit so
we'll grab this little top left button
right here
this is our guides and if you let's see
you should be able to click and drag yep
and you'll just
tell the program what are you know the
horizontal lines the vertical line so
i'm getting the top and i'm getting the
bottom you see what
you see how it stretched it out and it
matched it perfectly
so now the top and the bottom of this
concrete wall is flush with the top and
bottom of the frame
and you do the same for uh the vertical
lines so i'm seeing these vertical lines
up in here
so i'll grab that one and i'll grab this
one right here
and that will perfectly align
your 3d or essentially that will align
your image
to be as flat as possible you don't want
any weird angles if you want to stitch
all these images together
so i did that i cropped it propped it
down
making sure to actually maintain the
original
aspect ratio so i'm just bringing these
in like this
boom and that's the image and i did that
for all
50 of these pieces of wall
right just going through and getting
this whole thing there's so much detail
and texture
there's no way i could do this like
manually or not manually
i couldn't do it automatically i
couldn't go to qixel bridge
and do all of this i needed to actually
take the pictures myself
to get the look i wanted to get so once
i have all this let me open up photoshop
and i'll show you guys how i stitched
all these things together
and how i created a normal map you can
also create a roughness and specular map
too so i'm going to show you guys
exactly how i did that right now
thanks for joining me y'all thanks for
joining me on this saturday we're doing
it
uh we got a freaking cg live stream
going right now
let's see if i can't open up
some images here all right so let's um
let's see let me bring this on over for
y'all
and let me open up some of these
images all right let's find on the
navigate
here's the art vfx you got to keep your
folders organized here so you know where
your stuff is
endless concrete and we want the
processed
you know i just put them in the
processed folder and we'll go
with the
yeah let's go with the wall
there's a lot of images here so let's
see if we can't
find like just five images or something
these five and i'll just demonstrate on
these five images you can go
as long as you want like i'll show you
guys my final image let me let me show
you how ridiculous this final image is
it's too it was too long it was honestly
it had no business being this long
so this is the full length of i think
this is half though hold on
no that's the full amount or maybe i s
maybe i saved over it
um but that's basically yeah i think i
did save over it because it was just too
long
it was um it was like double or triple
this
length but if you go to 100
you can see the whole wall is stitched
together and you have a big old
big old wall to work with super cool
really awesome
i made sure to include like the the
nasty water on this side
freaking awesome okay so let me show you
how i stitch these together really quick
so i have all my images here in
photoshop
what you can do actually is you can go
to file
automate photo merge and you can select
auto here add open files to the stack
you have all these
let's go let's just check vignette
removal and
geometric distortion correction i don't
think we need to do geometric distortion
correction because we kind of already
like
i'm wondering what that is i'm wondering
if it fixes like the apple profile or if
that actually tries to
mesh the images into each other
but let's give it a shot let's see what
this does
then we should just get one long image
if we're lucky okay so it you know this
one it looked like this
one was kind of missing and this was a
thing i had to do this manually
for all these images but you guys get
the idea
kind of brought everything together and
what we can do here is actually
merge all this stuff control e
and we can crop it down
let's see
get width and height resolution
why sometimes i don't know how to use
photoshop
um where are you at ratio
no we don't want a ratio i just want to
go off the
god dang
y'all are probably screaming at me right
now like dude it's so easy
what are you doing here i'm gonna do it
the cheat way we'll do that
and then i'm just gonna i'm gonna trim
it
so if we go to image trim it'll get rid
of all the transparent pixels
except for the ones like it's not gonna
crop the image obviously
but here's what you can do you can
control click your image in the layer
here
and it should yep
highlight your image you guys can
probably see this little selection
going around here if you hit ctrl shift
i you'll invert the selection
and shift backspace will pop up this
fill option if you select select content
aware fill and hit ok
photoshop will do its best to fill in
these missing pixels and that's not that
bad of a job there that is not that bad
you could also
like liquefy it you know
and merge this so basically you could do
something where you like uh
let's see if i wanted to
there's probably a better way to do this
but if i want to use the liquify tool i
can
kind of just move
this down a little bit you guys get the
idea right you see how i'm like
stretching this to hit the border
and to be generally flush here with the
image
then we can hit ok and we can try
trimming it again
get rid of all those transparent pixels
and from here you could either crop it
or you could try the content aware fill
thing again
but in this case i would probably just
crop it so you said hold shift is that
is that the key what the heck holding
shift
does not do what i want it to do
yikes i should know this stuff right
see even even i'm a noob at photoshop
i'll do it the cheat way i'll take it
and i'll just
kind of scale it up a little bit holding
shift
bring those up there bring those down
there and that's looking good
yo we got our first super chat
of the day i believe i don't think i
missed any uh
jones lab thank you for the super chat
you say what up finishing my submission
after about 100 hours today
dang dude that is awesome um graphic
designer for 10 years this is my
favorite project ever thanks for the
motivation
dude thank you for um putting all of
your hard work into this thing
um the more you guys put into your
submissions the
more awesome the final montage is going
to be combining all these images
and all these renders together is going
to be truly epic
um so i actually
got the 122 submissions so far
and i put them out into da vinci and
i have a musician working on some music
right now so i
popped in his temp music and sat back
and it's it's incredible already
it's seriously incredible already
without the final music and without all
the renders it's
so cool to watch it syncs up and it's
amazing so i can't wait
to show you guys that final montage
which will be
middle of june middle of june so june
1st is the deadline
for the submissions that's going to be a
tuesday i believe
that saturday i'm going to have myself
and a couple guest judges
going over i believe the top 100 renders
because there's just
depending on how many there are there's
just going to be too many to do we'll
see though we'll see how many there are
um so we'll select the winners
immediately
right right after the june 1st delivery
on tuesday
that saturday that weekend the next live
stream will be
um the the i'll choose the winners
that's two live streams from now
after that will be montage
yes i am so excited i'm so excited
so guys keep up the hard work um i'm
gonna be cranking on my render today
here on the live stream and i know you
guys will be too so thank you for
joining me
so guys we're talking about how to make
custom textures right now though
we just stitched these concrete images
together in photoshop
using the file automate photo merge
option we had all of our images
that we took on our iphone i shot all of
these on my iphone
brought them into lightroom and cropped
them
and warped them so that they were
flush 90 degree perpendicular lines here
we don't want any
warped lines we want everything as
upright and square as possible
that way we can merge them together
properly here
just like this so we got everything
merged here
now the next thing
that we want to do is let's go and
select this
and let's duplicate it ctrl j
and we want to make a normal map all
right so this is your diffuse
map right we'll throw this down on a
let's do it let's freaking do it let's
hop into
into c4d i'll make a new file control n
and let's go ahead and render this let
me save out
this image i'm just going to go straight
to the desktop
because this is just a a demonstration
so we'll call this diffusion
bam all right i'm going to take note of
its dimensions okay so
we hover over this you can see 1919
by 330. all right so
in c4d let's make a plane
and it'll be 1919.
by 330. and if i make a new octane
material
and i drop that diffuse texture or that
diffuse
uh yeah diffuse texture technically that
is correct
into the diffuse channel
and drop that onto the plane then you'll
see we have
a brick wall that just kind of goes
right
but what if i want to load let's go
ahead and load
a an hdri
image here i'll link
the texture to hdri link let's open that
up
just so we can get uh i don't know
church
entrance all right let's select church
entrance that's blown out so we need to
select the image and set it to linear
that's gonna smooth it a little bit okay
so you see how it's super reflective
like it's a wet like wet pavement
well we don't want that right now we
actually want to give it a little bit
more depth we want some bump map we want
specular map roughness normal all that
good stuff right
you guys know how to build textures at
this point
so back in photoshop i didn't know this
i watched a win bush
tutorial um
and it blew my mind so if you go to
filter
3d generate normal map it'll do
exactly that it'll generate you a normal
map
boom look at that freaking awesome you
can select whether you invert it or not
so you can
be like okay i know that the paint here
they were trying to get rid of some
graffiti so
they're adding on to it so you want to
invert it so it looks like it's popping
out at you
um and then you can mess with all these
settings here like the detail scale you
can bring this down
make it not as intense you can crank it
up and like go to town with it that's
going to be crazy
but i think somewhere here is probably
nice
and then you can work the low values and
try and like bring out a little bit more
of the low end
maybe the medium scale here not doing
too much the high end
again not doing too much but maybe if we
come all the way up with the low end
this is a weird thing sometimes these
sliders don't work so if i hit cancel
and we try that one more time filter
3d generate normal map
right try typing in these values like 50
percent
and the medium goes to like 50 percent
and the high just 50 percent
everything straight 50 but i think it
gets a little bit more detailed when you
like drop it down
so let me try taking all this stuff down
to 20 and you see it didn't change
let's hit okay and see if it yeah
let's try it again filter 3d i think
that's just a bug
let's bring the detail scale up just a
little bit
right and this is fine this is fine you
guys can mess with all these settings
we'll hit ok and we're going to save
this out as our normal map
um jpeg yeah whatever
normal usually it'd be like a tiff or
like a png or something
um dang son mr hanshauser bosch
back in the house with the freaking
super chats
my god um dropping bombs here man
thank you for that my goodness thank you
sir thank you thank you
that's going to help me pay for some of
the the cg assets i've had to purchase
to create my render um man that's
awesome
so you say can't wait to see everyone's
projects come together i agree
it really is special there is nothing
like this right now
where everyone is putting all this work
into their one
render and com we're combining all of it
into like so many hours of work it'd be
cool to actually take a tally
and say like how many hours of work
this is total like that would be cool
like we have the stats
how much render time how many hours of
work
um how many frames total like that'd be
sweet and mr hans hauser bosh
had a good time participating as well so
thank you for that super chat man very
generous of you always always
um very much appreciated um i'm glad you
had a good time with it
yeah let's get back to it guys
indie story i'm excited to see your
render dude
very excited to see yours you're very
very talented
very good with unreal engine and hey by
the way guys by the way
this is very important if you're using
unreal engine
um to create your alternate realities
render then please make sure you check
the info channel
on my discord server the alternate
realities
you know channels and download the
unreal engine update okay
you can either download the new project
file or you can just type in
the data manually basically what
happened is the camera was off
so if you render your final submission
with the camera in the wrong place
that's no good so make sure you guys
check the info channel if you're using
unreal engine to create your art
check it and just change two values it's
all in there okay it's very simple
you gotta go in the sequencer and change
two values all right
so make sure your your camera is in the
right place if you're using unreal
engine
and glenn thank you for the super chat
as well much appreciated
um heck yeah dude anything is helpful
anything is helpful
you rock man thank you for the support i
appreciate you glenn
heck yeah let's get back to it
all right so our normal map all right
let's load on our normal map into c4d
and see what it looks like so
let me just hop into here
and i'll just put this up into here so
we have a little bit more room
um and let's see if we can't just
uh drag this image
that normal map right in and let's see
what it does so take a look at the
render view
drop the normal map in and yeah it does
a little something
it's a little too glossy right now so i
think it needs
um it needs a roughness and a specular
channel working on it um however
it's pretty low res i'm not gonna lie
it's pretty low res
but that's because i took the pictures
with my iphone
um so if i'm do i'm actually going to go
back
and redo this with my dslr and i think
i'm
i think my next texture pack is going to
be
it's going to be called endless concrete
and i'm going to just do a bunch of
these for you guys
and i'll have it on gum road for i don't
know something affordable
absolutely and i think i'm going to put
together a video
on the process uh some fun
vlog video where i go out and i shoot
all this stuff i show you guys how i'm
doing it
and then i show you the exact process in
photoshop and i'll sell
sell the pack at the end very similar to
the service imperfection
video and and john
johnson yo thanks for the super chat man
heck yeah uh cool beanie i'm glad
i'm glad you like the beanie um
i like it too thanks for the drink money
man i appreciate it
i'll get some tea maybe i'll get some uh
some kombucha maybe i'll get
who knows man maybe some wine or
something yeah
um thank you thank you sir
okay so let's let's create uh our
specular
and our uh our roughness channel here so
let's come up in here
and i'm going to simply make
a black and white adjustment layer here
uh where are you black and white bam
so this can pretty i mean this can
easily be your
um your your specular channel here
we can say that the graffiti
is like the paint over the graffiti
could be more reflective
than the actual concrete wall and the
like these these areas where oh god dang
it
i did it i did it again so
the paint where the graffiti is can be
more reflective because it's whiter
right so black is going to be
non-reflective and white is going to be
reflective
or the other way around but i'm pretty
sure that's correct
so we can say that the graffiti areas
are going to be a bit more reflective
because you know they're paint it's
paint
so it catches a bit more light and then
the areas
that are darker here like this crack
will be
less reflective in the wall itself
it'll be a series of grays and darks and
lights so i think this is actually
pretty nice
i'm gonna go ahead and save this as our
specular
and let's see what it looks like back
into cinema
we'll try and get a nice reflective
point like yeah here we go here we go
something like this
and let's go ahead and drop that image
in here
bam and guys remember if you're in
octane
i don't know if any other renderers do
this but if you're an octane and you
want to save
vram so that you can make your scenes
more complicated
um take your black and white images set
the type to float
and that's basically by default octane
is assuming that all of your textures
are color textures and there's more
data more bits and bytes in color
textures than there are in black and
white textures
so don't have your black and white
textures um be color textures
you're just wasting space so yeah let's
put that into the specular
and then you can see it's kind of it's
doing a little thing here
let me see here if um some contrast
could help so i'm going to go
to color correction drop a color
correction node and i'll just
boost the contrast by 20 or something
and there you can see it's we're getting
these nice streaks here
and yep this is very reflective here
on the little paint areas so it looks
pretty darn cool to me now what we could
do
is basically
work in a roughness of roughness
texture so
one way to do it is just go to the
roughness and set it to like point two
or something so it all kind of gets
smoothed out
equally which isn't that bad and it's a
little reflective so maybe we can take
uh the specular
channel the float and just take that
down by half maybe
or am i on the wrong let's see am i
wrong
no that should be correct let's see
we go to specular and we take the float
all the way down to zero
why is that still reflective
oh because it's i see it's because it's
um
is it getting the the color correction
node
if i were to plug this specular in let's
take that roughness down to zero
and then let's try that again
is it the mix that needs to come down
interesting
all right so let's try that again bring
the mix down
so it's just not as intense um and let's
try using the same image
as the roughness i'm just going to ctrl
drag
drop that into the roughness channel and
see what
happens
um indie story yo dude thank you for the
super chat your stuff is so good i can't
wait to see your submission
um yeah you're welcome i think this
challenge
is a really cool way for people to get
inspired and create cool stuff
and you're saying that it really made
you push yourself in unreal and learn
new things
yes that's the whole point we gotta
learn new stuff i
haven't done a um a custom texture
before
so i'm in the same boat dude we're all
learning and growing together and that
again is the whole point
of this channel is so we can learn and
grow together
um so you say you barely get time after
work but gets you excited to stay up
late and create new worlds
heck yeah dude me too man me too
thank you for that super chat thank you
for the support and thank you for
participating in the challenge man i
can't wait to see your final
all right what if we invert this
roughness
uh i see
let's maybe give this a color correction
node too
and crank the let's crank the gamma see
what happens we crank the gamma
down
feel like it just needs to be really
subtle contrast let's try
20 on the contrast
and maybe i'll take the the noise or the
um the normal
texture and bring it down by half and
then let's
also take uh the specular and bring that
down
by half so it's just a bit more subtle
and you know if you do these right if
you do this with a dslr
it's really going to look nice but yeah
for what i'm doing
i was fine to use my iphone um
because in my in my my render
it's not going to be super close up
yeah and then the bump channel i mean
you could also go back into photoshop
and start messing with let's duplicate
this one more time
i think it actually has a displacement
option so you can go filter
3d generate bump or height map
so let's see what this does it looks a
little blurry
but let me let me just try this let me
see what this looks like um
let's hit okay on this and let's let's
save it out see what it looks like
so i'll desktop it jpeg and we'll call
this um
displacement
and let's drop it in isn't it really
cool that you can do all this from
photoshop
i never knew it until i watched
winbush's tutorial
let's drag this placement out get
displacement node drop that on
and it's going to do a thing so we can
do
let's see in the displacement mid level
is always 0.5 and let's just set it to
4k
resolution and we'll set it to like 20
or even 100
so we can get an idea of what's going on
okay
so it looks like the edges are a little
weird but if we set the height to maybe
like
yeah 20
we can get a little something out of
that just a little something
very cool
now it might be a little heavy on these
painted parts
so you'd have to go back in there and
essentially like
tone them down so this white is coming
up a little too much so you need to come
in here with like a gray brush
and and get those back down to be more
of the gray of the background itself
and that's where and why
custom textures can be expensive because
there's a lot of manual detail work that
goes into making this look nice
for example the water spot you know i
had that water
streak coming down that i had to make
sure
i had to basically do like custom
roughness custom specular maps
um on that just because
you know water is reflective it's not
the same as the concrete so
yeah um scorn yo
michael scorn dude thank you for the
super chat
you really enjoyed the challenge
couldn't manage to get a 4k render done
as needed
um the pc for other things also learned
so much yeah it's all right
all good dude uh the 1080p is totally
fine
um but you're looking forward to the
next one then and the next one
is coming around the corner all right
and it's going to be very different from
what we're doing
on this one it's going to be very fun
it's already in the works and i'm just
excited for you guys to get into it yeah
it's going to be sweet
what's up ronin we got ronin the
moderator up in here
holding it down um thank you i
appreciate you for that man
okay so while octane thinks really hard
here we go so i'll show you guys that
little water spot
that i did
yeah this one here i i need to uh
tile this a little bit differently it
looks a little stretched doesn't it
see if i can't just
drop this length
that feels a bit better yeah
so you can see it's a bit more
reflective at certain parts
um more reflective than the wall itself
a better example honestly is this ground
so the ground here for this
what i did was i actually went
underneath a bridge
and i took a bunch of shots again with
my iphone
um of the ceiling of the bridge and it's
these giant concrete structures
um and i stitched them together the same
way and then i took
a basically a reference picture of this
drain
and i took the water from it and i
brought that
into photoshop and combined this texture
of this the underneath of the bridge
with
this water and i made sure that the
water was more reflective you know again
going back to like that custom nature of
these textures i made sure that the
water
was going to be more reflective than the
concrete itself so
yeah that's that's essentially what i
did to make this custom
bridge or waterway drain i don't know
um to create this look and it really
works it's
super solid and i'm really really happy
with how it turned out
so what's the meat of this stream what
are we gonna do
um i'm gonna build out this sewer
with a bunch of like mud and
uh foliage a bunch of shrubs
a bunch of uh what else are we gonna do
we're gonna do
like some garbage in the corners
and we're really gonna make it look
nasty and muddy and i'm just gonna
detail this out
like i detailed out my foreground
last week the background
buildings i'm probably going to save
for this week i'm going to work on them
this week
and probably touch them up this weekend
on the final stream um
and then i'll get into character stuff
over the weekend as you guys are
submitting your final renders
shout out to visual another one of our
moderators um but honestly the dude is
just uh
he's much more than a moderator as all
the moderators are they're not just
moderators
they're fantastic artists so
um it's cool to cool to have you guys up
in here
um and i appreciate your guys's help so
visual thank you so much sir
faraz yo what's going on dude
welcome thank you for joining
yes visuals starting his entry today
yo better late than never um
i feel like i still have a lot of work
on mine
a lot of work on mine
like i'm not to be honest with you i'm
not really liking my render right now
remember how i was talking about it
yesterday or last week
i was saying how ah you don't like it
but then you spend more time on it and
you start to like it
i'm i'm in that zone right now where
it's like
i'm i'm i'm back and forth up and down
on this one i'm like i don't know
i don't know once the whole thing comes
together then i can start shaping and
really getting the visual contrast and
the visual
um composition down that's the thing
that
i'm not digging right now is the visual
composition and the color
but i know that once i get to an
end point once i have the buildings in
there once i can actually see kind of
like a
near final looking image i'll be able to
come in here and start tweaking stuff
to really make it shine and really have
the render
feel as good as possible and i am going
to do a breakdown of this render
like i did with the car next to the
ocean with the
you know foggy factory i'm gonna do one
for this too
so i wanna talk to you guys about
everything that just is going through my
mind while i'm doing this
in a compact form but yeah
zerge is correct just gotta keep going
just gotta keep going
all right
so let's build out this uh this sewer
system thingy it'd be cool to have some
pipes coming out of the side of the wall
um it would be cool to have maybe some
like
shafts and tunnels potentially we'll see
how that could go um it would be sweet
to have
a bunch of like shrubs growing down the
middle and growing down like different
little strips of this thing
it would be cool to have a bunch of dirt
and like old wet paper and mud
and grime collected in the corners maybe
with some dead leaves and sticks and
rocks
in the corners and depending it would be
really cool to have
a uh
i don't know maybe some sort of like
robot or car or something down here like
some sort of like
eye-catching little visual piece of
contrast
it would be cool so
let us begin also i might have
i'm just realizing this right now um let
me pull up my pref
stuff for you guys
how crazy is this huh look at this
so scary
what the heck i'm stuck
why am i stuck why can't i zoom out
anyway um like this
right here that this is a dude that's a
dude
and i might do something similar with my
um with my render here instead of a
giant hole in the background i might
actually just have the sewer go
into a giant like wash
pit thingy i think that would be sick
i'll be super sick this is the same one
isn't that terrifying that's like that
is the the creepiest thing i've ever
seen in my life
and i want i just want more of this i
want more of this
i want to do a render very similar to
this
in the future i think that could be
really cool i showed you guys this stuff
on the last stream
and here's an example of kind of like
the sewer here it's like another
sewer but again i don't know what this
is
it's not the river it's not the la river
even though i took the shots in the la
river
um but i don't know what this is a wash
of
who knows
what else do we got what else do we got
yeah i think that's that's good for the
for the reference i just wanted to show
you guys that one
all right
so where do we begin
we could start with
man it would be cool to have just that
giant hole
but for now i think let's just start
with like some corner
detail all right so let me
let me make my render a little larger
and let's scale this up
technology within us that's a funny
question that's a very funny question
thank you visual
i appreciate you i'm not answering that
that's a personal question son getting
back to it
all right um let's uncheck the check
camera option
let's hop out of camera view let's save
our work
and let's start creating
all right so the ground plane here's
what i want to do
i essentially want to make
some topography to clone some stuff onto
all right so um basically these little
like
the gutter what is it like the gutter
ball when you get the gutter ball
in bowling it's the one that goes to the
side and gets stuck in the gutter
yeah i want my little gutter polygons
here
because i'm going to be able to create
some stuff off of that so i'll select
the floor here and let's go ahead
and let's grab bam bam and bam bam we'll
grab both of those just like that yep
i'm gonna hit up that's breakup up
that's gonna disconnect those pieces
yeah
from the drain okay so let's group this
let's call this
uh main drain
and this will be our corner
scatter name your stuff
gotta name your stuff
oh visual that's funny dude um
let's get rid of these little edges we
don't need these edges uh m
n m n
i'm just gonna get rid of that we don't
need it
all right corner scatter
let's hit up let's
hit up the mega scans assets
and let's see if we can't find um
some mud nah let's hit rd textures let's
just drop
some mud up on that
and we'll render region so we're only
rendering what we
need awesome
okay it's actually let's see what this
one i know that we had like
this guy bam this guy right here from
last
week the ground edge mud
this one here it was a rubble floor too
there it is rubble floor two let's try
rubble floor two
right up on that as very reflective
um
so i think what we'll need to do is just
make a new texture
maybe this concrete what is this
concrete rubble
um these are all yeah okay okay
trying to figure out what texture works
the best
oops i didn't mean to do that
go back to our little gutter
corner scatter here we go
and i'm just trying different
different textures ooh that one's not
bad
that one's not bad at all it feels like
real slimy and nasty
so we can take that and
that corner scattered let's go ahead and
grab these
edges and bring them down and then bring
the whole corner scatter thing up so it
just kind of goes
down into the concrete you see that look
at that
that's nice
so before and after so without
and with you're getting a little bit of
that nastiness
just a little bit of that nastiness you
know
it's really nice and it adds so we're
going to keep adding on to this
so let's duplicate the corner scatter
and let's get something a little little
chunkier up in the mix
bam drop that guy in there i like how
it's a little wet
very nice we can potentially
bring this up and let's like bring let's
bring these guys
in towards each other so i'm going to
just kind of scale them in towards each
other
and we'll bring that down just a little
bit
so maybe it's too much maybe it's too
much maybe we just need a little bit of
chunkage
up in the corner so i'm gonna undo what
we did there bam
let's actually do the opposite let's
scale them out so it's just a little
tiny piece
a little strip
of that chunkiness
yeah you see that now it's like you
start to see that wet
nastiness collect up in the corners
that's good that's good we could also
let's duplicate that texture
and i'm going to call this mud and then
i'll call this one
[Music]
mud
mud dry maybe
because it's a little i don't know
that's a little intense
but it looks i don't know it looks good
also what i'm gonna do let's go to
displacement i just want like little
pieces popping up
through um the ground so i'll set the
displacement to
30.
and the reason i duplicated it is
because
um i don't want like we're using this
main mud we're using this in our
foreground
and i don't want to mess with the way it
looks so i'm duplicating it
so that i can actually get a a different
look out of it
let's
make sure the mapping is correct on that
so maybe i'll set this to cubic
mm-hmm and i'll scale it up we're going
to tile it point one times
no maybe i need to get up in here
probably the best way to do it
yeah that seems right
sweet okay
back to camera view just render region
and i'm going to just drop it down again
it's so subtle it's very very subtle but
that's okay that's
that's really what we want let's see
negative
281
negative 280 yeah that comes up a little
bit
yeah very very subtle
and let's take the specular
and just drop the specular down a little
bit
awesome okay
william what's up dude hey good to see
you man
your render is looking insane um
holy crap i don't know if you submitted
yet but keep it up dude
keep it up that's amazing
all right so i think
let's try and get maybe a little bit
of how do i want to do this
i think it's going to be wise to have
some plants and shrubs
down the middle of this thing because
that was actually happening
in real life let me show you guys the
reference image
uh where are we at the art vfx
assets endless concrete raw
here we go so you guys will notice
that these bushes here
are kind of chilling right up in the
middle where the water is they're
growing where the water is
you also have some shrubs right along
the these like little cracks also where
water probably pulls into these cracks
and grows some some weeds and shrubs and
stuff and then there's a lot of like
stuff collected in the middle or on the
edges
these are a bunch of leaves from the
trees up here um but we don't have any
trees in our scene really and we don't
have dead leaves but we can have rocks
and rubble
you know again collecting in the corner
and kind of scattered throughout this
whole thing
so this is definitely where
we'll be using this as a reference to
you know to really max out
our our little scene here
all right so
bushes and shrubs you know a lot of that
you can use
from the mega scans library there's a
lot of good stuff there but i'm probably
going to be using
full um forester
for my stuff just because it's easy it's
quick here
so what i'm going to do is i'll still
have those edges there
those little planes that we have as a
scatterable kind of uh kind of
surface for our plants to be scattered
and spread out on
so i need to do that for the middle too
so let's see if i
can't let's lock that let's hop out of
our camera
and do this you know very similar thing
that we did before
let's grab these middle pieces
up we'll break them up
and let's just name our stuff here this
is wall one
wall two
middle
yeah middle i guess uh this is our floor
that's our corner scatter and this is
our middle scatter
okay
so let's find the plants and the shrubs
that we want to
[Music]
distribute along our uh
along our sewer here i also want to make
sure
that
i'm not scattering yeah that's actually
perfect
that is perfect if i hit shift v or no
alt v
we can go to save frames set save frames
and you can actually see where this cuts
off so we actually don't need
any of this in the foreground we don't
need to scatter
on that at all so i'm going to actually
delete
those polygons so we don't get confused
we don't need to waste
any computer juice at any point during
this render because
it's going to start getting really rare
let's go to the drain the middle scatter
okay we can delete that and the main
drain
the main drain we can delete all that
the walls i'll leave the walls for now
and the corner scatter i will actually
clip as well so kl
is your cut tool bam we'll just get
those and delete
what we don't need whatever you don't
see there's no need to see it
now technically you don't want any light
influencing your scene from the bottom
so what we can do is actually put a
a plane down here with like a gray
solid on it
that way it's stopping any light from
coming in where you don't want it
but i'd rather use this than you know a
bunch of detail and shrubs that you
don't see
in the frame right so we can just get
like a
non-descript matte middle gray
kind of texture for that plane there
maybe even a little darker so it doesn't
bounce
a bunch of light you know what i mean
fabian yo welcome welcome to the first
ever
live stream i'm glad you're joining me
very cool stuff
all right let's populate this thing with
some rubbery
so um like i said i'm using forester so
let's go to extensions
where are you forrester and we'll do
a multi
flora is that what we want do we want
a flower as long as it's like a weed
you know we want like a little weed um
let's go to
[Music]
the material selection no the library we
want the library
yeah this is what we want so looking at
my reference
let me go back to this reference here
just to get an idea of what kind of
stuff we're seeing um
very sparse it's very sparse not super
detailed
and it might be wiser to be honest with
you guys it might be wiser just to
use the mega scans
shrubs and stuff because they're gonna
be
they're gonna be a lot more render
friendly
and i might use let me okay so while i'm
here
i'll populate the middle section with
bushes and stuff
that you can't really get with mega
scans so let's do that at least
and for the bushes i think what we can
do is actually use a tree instead
and turn a tree into a bush so we'll go
forester
forester tree
and let's drop us down here and let's
see if we can't do
the tree library and let's hit up
something that looks like a bush
um
hmm a sycamore i don't know
uh pseudo camellia
prospius so you can't really see the
leaves in here
but if we go to tree parameters and we
change the viewport level a little
higher you should be able to see
some greenery
it's really thinking hard here
it's just very render intensive right
now
there you go that's a lot isn't it
that's a whole lot
a lot of stuff we don't need
so what we can do is
take the tree growth to like point one
and it's thinking really hard
hopefully this thing will get a little
smaller yeah forester is totally worth
it 300 bucks for forester absolutely
um it has a wind option
and it's just it's just the best i
really do enjoy it
so this is taking a long time it's
really thinking very hard
i'm wondering if we can just use
mega scans for this let me open up mega
scans here
and let's hit up these 3d plants
hmm ferns i do love me some ferns
um so weeds
we'll get some of that some grass we'll
get some of that
let's try ferns and see what they have
you can have this stuff growing out the
middle
let's see what else they got
maybe some grass perhaps
some wild overgrown grass i think will
definitely be a part of our scene
so maybe some of these like small guys
here these wild little wild grass pieces
let's download the 8k
and we'll export
the 2k version because they're going to
be very small
and that's going to come right into c4d
let's get rid of this tree and let's
take a look at these shrubs
these little grassy grasses
all right so
if we re-render our scene hopefully we
should
be able to see these things here
how many more days you have left for the
challenge i think there's like nine days
left or something
nine days in like eight hours
dang did octane crash what's going on
maybe it did
let me let me just restart let me
restart cinema here
absolutely save my work
that's the name of the game y'all
sometimes yep that's an octane crash for
you
computers are computers a little tricky
sometimes they crash
you know that's just the way it is
for whatever reason cinema never opens
for you you can hit a control shift
escape if you're on pc
and it's probably because you're running
cinema
in the background it'll say cinema 4d
somewhere up in here and you just want
to make sure you close it out
but we don't need lightroom anymore we
don't need photoshop anymore
i did it again didn't i yeah control
shift escape
and in your processes if you see cinema
4d
down here in the background processes
and it's not booting for you that means
you're still running it
so you can just make sure you close it
out
all right
we will render our scene and once we can
see these shrubs
we'll start uh scattering them in the
little gutter areas
and maybe we can scatter them on some
other tiny little strips
of uh of concrete that can act as like
the cracks in the ground and stuff
flow ed thank you sir that's very
very kind of you i appreciate it man i'm
glad you enjoy the streams
all right when you see your bright
yellow updating
that means you're close and it should
yeah here we go
so what we want to do right we got our
little shrubbies our shrubby shrubs
let's go ahead and go into
our actual scene here scene view let's
open this up just a bit
oh no oh my god no no not four
that would be very bad
and i'm just going to render this region
here
that's all we need to see is this the
corner bits
awesome okay and we'll uncheck check
camera so we can hop out of this view
and create
so what i want to do essentially is just
take all of these guys
and scatter them
wait why did it stop again
did octane crash again
anyway let's let's try this all right
let's take all these
i can use an octane scatter if i wanted
to
and i think that's probably what i'll do
is i'll do it with an octane scatter
yeah
so let's go ahead and make an octane
scatter object you know by going to
objects
octane scatter and i'm just gonna drop
all these guys
in that octane scatter and in the octane
scatter options the count is already at
a thousand i'm gonna set it to just a
hundred
and it's looking for a surface all right
and we wanna put it on the surface of
this
surface and the surface will be our
the corner scatter like we had selected
right corner scatter one
and i think that's
yeah corner scatter is totally fine so
let's go ahead and select octane scatter
let's drag our corner scatter
bam into the surface and you can see
that we have
these lines that are basically our
little shrubs
let's hop back into camera view try
re-rendering octane i don't know why it
crashed again
mason thank you for joining it's your
first time welcome welcome
um we got a lot of a lot of newcomers
today guys that's awesome
yeah it looks like i'm getting some
weird
octane issues that's no good
apologies y'all i'ma try it one more
time
yep another octane bug let's give it the
ol
open up c4d again and we'll try one more
time
if you guys are enjoying yourselves and
having a good saturday give me a thumbs
up
in the live chat it's always good to see
y'all
all right let's try this one more time
bam
i know i need a better processor
i really do
ah man i am so sore from rock climbing
yesterday
we went for like five hours or so
and i was telling you guys earlier in
the stream i learned how to set anchors
and tie
you know tie the the ropes and all the
knots up top
and it was a little stressful it was a
little stressful
don't want to mess that up no siree not
at all
all right let's try
to render region one more time
looks like it's working i'll uncheck the
check camera option
and we'll hop out of the camera
hopefully
it looks like it's working okay so um
let's try and
now these big ones these little big
bushes are a little too much okay so i'm
gonna scale down these big ones
i don't want it to be too intense there
on the edges
sweet
and we want to add a random effector
to the mix here because we want to
randomly rotate these shrubs we don't
want them all in the same orientation
so uncheck position and we'll check
rotation
and we can look at these splines just as
reference here so if i rotate and it
looks like nothing's happening that's
because they're rotating
on the y-axis these other axes
oh okay so nothing's happening that's
because the octane scatter needs to
you need to drag the random effector
into it
then it'll start working so yep
that will actually orient these plants
hopefully
1080 and then let's go a little bit
a little bit of angle on these guys bam
all right that looks good
and i think i actually think octane is
bugging out on me
when i'm doing like this whole
combination of uncheck check camera
render
region um i think that's the issue
which is unfortunate so we're going to
go one last time and just make sure we
don't do that again
sorry guys hope you're all still
enjoying yourselves
what does gi clamp do that's a good
question um
the biggest use for gi clamp is
by default it's set to a million and
you're gonna get a lot of fireflies a
lot of hot pixels a lot of little white
dots that just don't look right in your
render
and the easiest way to get rid of those
is by taking your gi clamp to one
so by default i'm always setting my gi
clamp to one
and you can actually go window
customization
save as default scene and that will have
that
fix for you every time you open c4d
so gi clamp bam set to one and that
essentially like
i don't know exactly but it has
something to do with like the light
and how far the light is traveling to
reference your stuff
and you don't need it you don't need to
go in a million
points in that direction you just kind
of want it to focus on
i don't know i i can't explain it i
hadn't looked at the
documentation so i can't i can't really
explain it
but let's render our scene again
global illumination clamp nice that's
what it stands for okay
yeah so it's like how much light how
much
how how far do you want to illuminate
things a million points in that
direction or just one point in that
direction i'm gonna say that direction
it's a it's a global thing it's like a
sphere
do you want your sphere of light to be a
million times large or just one times
large
and for most scenes one times large is
just large enough
all right let me test this out and see
if this works
render region let me start messing with
these
settings
yeah that looks like it's working all
right
so octane scatter let's try 200.
we're getting like a bunch of grass up
in the corner there
and the random let's go like 40 degrees
40 degrees so they're kind of all over
the place a little bit
and we can mess with the size as well
so in the random effector we can check
the scale we can do
uniform scale we'll definitely want
uniform and we can set it to one so
it'll either scale up by one or down by
one
i wonder if we type negative one
[Music]
and we can again hit t and scale all
this stuff down
so it's a little smaller and
i want
i want some more shrubs coming into the
foreground a little bit
so i need to see like what
is that scattering on it's scattering on
this bit i can just
mess with the seed so the seed is gonna
distribute these plants
a little bit more randomly you can just
like switch through the seed here
get a different look
you set that to 400 if you want you know
really like
you have a bunch of stuff coming out
there 300 maybe
and you see how they're going like too
far into
the actual concrete so we can scale that
back by
duplicating the let's see the corner
scatter or even taking the corner
scatter
and kind of
scaling it in a little bit we'll grab
both of those hit t
and just kind of bring them in a touch
wow but i like the look of that so
here's what we'll do we'll duplicate
corner scatter
we'll call this um
corner shrub scatter and we'll use that
instead
so that we're really just trying to get
as much control over
all these individual elements as
possible
nice very nice cool that that totally
works
yeah we have a little bit more shrubs
there in the corner then
and then another thing we could do
actually this is actually uh
i think a pretty cool technique
hopefully this doesn't crash octane
again we will see
but let's create like a series of
little cracks and stuff like here you
can see that this
this crack goes along down the uh
the path here and there's different
little shrubs growing within that
so i want to see if we can't uh
replicate this kind of look so what
we'll do for
that is essentially
create um let's make a plane
now in fact let's not let's not make a
plane let's select this ground here
the floor all right we're going to
duplicate
the floor
and we're going to use this to kind of
like chop up and let's go ahead and like
let's solo it
and let's make some cuts so kl
and we'll make a cut here we'll make a
cut
here and we're just kind of making some
grooves going down
this concrete make a cut there
there and we'll do like a couple
that go horizontally
down this thing so we can kind of get a
little sense of depth
we'll equally space these out
a little something like that and we can
scatter these plants
along these pieces all right so
let's go ahead and select all these
little grooves that we made so ul
is a loop selection tool we'll go into
edge mode or
face mode and we'll select
all of these little like channels these
runways
and we gotta get in there
and these are the these are the little
like cracks and strips where our
grass and our weeds are going to grow
perfect so from here we can hit ui and
then delete everything else
so we just have this little bit here
we can name this
let's see let's name this um
i don't know um
[Music]
ground crack scatter i don't know
that works and let's start with the
shrubs that we already have okay
we can actually take that ground crack
scatter
and we have this texture that is that we
have on it we can duplicate that texture
and we can actually make it darker to
appear
like there actually are cracks in the
ground so
let's take the brightness down to like
point one
hop out of the solo mode
and see if this works
let's bring the ground crack scatter up
out of the floor
by like one point so
52 so that we actually see it
yep now that now we actually see them
running down the length
of that's perfect
wonderful wonderful and we can make them
a little darker too
so we can do like
negative 0.02 they're really dark
awesome and now all we need to do
is let's duplicate the scatter that
octane scatter
and let's point it to this little ground
crack system that we set up
yeah that's super cool and what we could
do is actually scale down
let's try scaling all these guys down
just a little bit
so it's a bit more subtle
and let's go ahead and
see if we can't distribute these shrubs
with some noise all right
so let's set it to a thousand
so there's a lot of shrubs going down
all these little channels
and yeah it's basically to just make it
not as uniform
um
so let's see let's see if we can't
select that let's go to distribution
we'll go to
the shader will throw in a noise
let's set the contrast to a hundred
and we'll set the scale
global scale to a thousand and see if
that does anything it doesn't look like
it's really doing anything um
maybe the
up vector normal align
[Music]
the count 500 maybe
maybe we just do less count maybe just
go 200 it'd be nice to get this to work
i think
i've never really like solved this one
it's always been a thing for me
that's why i always use the random
effector as opposed to all these guys
but you should be able to get them to
not be in certain parts based off of
this noise map
yeah i think i'll have to do a little
bit more research with that one
vertex map use it in scale all right
let's see
let's try it shader noise
this looks to work um contrast 100
yeah that's working global scale
let's take the count up to a thousand
yeah
that looks like it's working we can also
do it with size too
i know that is we are in scale okay so
maybe instead of
a hundred contrasts we do
90 contrast
mess with the brightness a little bit
that kind of works you can adjust the
scaling of some of these guys
awesome
feels pretty nice
yeah that's awesome okay so from here we
want to have
some bushes and shrubs down the middle
as well
so let's go ahead and scatter
let's go ahead and grab a couple more
bushes
from the mega scans
gallery
hmm
i think you can like switch out a bunch
of different variations too
some dead stuff would be nice that this
is actually some good stuff some like
thatching grass
yeah let's try this um
looks like i already have it i can
export the 2k version
um
one second guys hold on one second i
gotta move my car
i will be back give me two minutes see
you guys in a second
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right y'all back to it back to it
so yeah we just exported some of this
grass here let's see if we can get one
more
if it's for the middle we want it to be
a little bit larger
um because the middle is actually going
to grow a little bit more because that's
where all the water
so let's see if we can't go ground cover
maybe
hmm
[Music]
herbs a bunch of mint leaves
some sage up in there
interesting um a ginger plant huh okay
weeds because technically they would be
really tall weeds
so it could be a mix of stuff here we
could do like some cheese weed
um maybe a little bit of this prickly
lettuce
i want something pretty full you know
we'll probably have a few different
types oh this is nice
sidewalk vegetation yeah dry plant set
and sidewalk let's get these two this is
nice
this is like exactly what we want for uh
for like the ground cracks and stuff so
maybe we'll use this for the ground
cracks or we'll mix this
we'll just mix it all in
dry plant set this is great for corners
too
so we'll export both of these 2k
versions
definitely don't need the 4k versions
because there's just going to be a lot
of them
we want to save as much as possible
and this one is nice too i'll download
this and export the 2k
all right
let's grab all this stuff there's a lot
wow that's a lot
geez okay
we should have done this one at a time
um let's go
let's take things behind the camera
and see if we can't sort all this stuff
out variation
1 through 12
13 14 15 16 70 wow that's a lot
so we got that stuff we have this other
stuff variation one through
fourteen
and one through eleven
and one through three okay cool so let's
deal with these
one at a time here
this stuff
is the fresher stuff that i think we can
pile up into the middle
of this okay so let's go ahead
and
and set that up yeah
so i'll make a scatter i'll drop those
three into the scatter
and i'll tell the scatter to scatter on
the let's see ground or no it's the
drain
middle scatter bam and instead of vertex
it's going to be the surface
and we have yep a lot of the same plant
so what we could do is use that same
random effector
to mess with the orientation we want to
mix up that orientation
and obviously it's way too uniform
and there's just too many pieces being
scattered
let's try a hundred
and it looks a little too dark
you know we can take these the tall weed
here and set it to glossy
and octane same for the dry plant in the
sidewalk we'll just set all the stuff
to glossy and octane
and what we can probably do is have a
couple different middle
scatter pieces so this middle scatter we
can actually take
and crunch it down a little bit
and then we could have uh middle scatter
2
be a little bit wider and middle scatter
3 just be
the full wide that way we can kind of
taper off
these shrubs and have them just be a
little bit taller in the middle
let's go to that octane scatter
let's go to the scale
we can actually scale them all up by
hitting t we'll scale them up
and we want to distribute these a little
bit
more randomly so
like we learned we'll go to that scale
option
we'll drop in some noise
we can set the contrast to i don't know
50 percent contrast
so that way you have full size ones and
then half size ones
and then all throughout
actually just to see what it's doing
i'll set it to 100
and i'll set the global scale to 500.
let's work the seed
we can take the global scale to 500.
i want to find one that's a little bit
more broken up like this is pretty nice
yeah maybe something like that we can
set the global scale to 50.
and they're a little too small so i'll
take
this scale on the random effector down
oh ian hubert up in here dude what's up
ian
yo
is that the true ian hubert that is the
question
um ian all right let's let's find out if
it is
indeed i don't think i don't think so
though
is it really ian is it really ian
because ian i have a question for you
i have a question for you ian and this
will be the ultimate test
to see if this really is true ian hubert
that only an ian
hubert and i could know the answer to
um
when
huh
okay okay what is what is the question
only ian
knows the answer to um
[Music]
let's see when i came up to
seattle to visit you last time no no ian
ian ian
what food do you have to get
every time you come down to los angeles
when you visit there's like that one
food that you're like yo this is the one
that i need to get every time what is
that food
this is the ultimate test
yeah it's yeah that's the right answer
noodles
sweet dude what's up ian
good to see you dude freaking great to
see you
thanks for hopping in man
people uh people are really excited
about this that's awesome you're making
a lot of people's days
so i'm working on my render right now
um it's a big old render
and i'm trying to like populate this
sewer
to look uh to look nice trying to make
it look grungy and nasty
and we're just scattering some plants
and shrubs right now
hmm
let's see what should we do here what
should we do i need a little bit more oh
i need that sidewalk nastiness that's
what we need is the sidewalk stuff
um let's try dropping in
another chunk
of of plants here so let me take
all of these out and let's see if we
can't
pop these guys in and see the difference
hmm okay kind of difficult to tell
maybe we'll do these ones here and let's
try
all these guys
ah they're so tiny they're so
small
let's try flipping these out again
the answer to everything is noodles the
answer to everything is
noodles but you can't
you can't overdo it you know i had some
of those noodles last night ian and my
goodness they're delicious
they are the they are the best
man yeah maybe i'll get rid of the noise
up in here i'll just clear that out so
it's full
let's see what we're dealing with here
we got these guys we got this grass this
is the stuff right here dude
these are the ones i want to scatter
that all up in
it and then we have
these guys the dead the dead stuff so i
want to mix probably these
and these guys
this dry thatching i don't know yeah
it's all i like these colors here
the dead stuff and this stuff right here
like this stuff that's not bad but let's
see if we can't get these guys working
variation 1 through 14
um let's get these guys
up in scatter number one
very nice
um
i'm just gonna make sure
and if it's really you
send me a text message
right now just to be sure
just to be super sure
i'm sure it is dude have a good one
peace out dude
later
you never know you gotta be extra
careful these days you know what i mean
gotta be extra careful
all right but you only had noodles once
in la dude it's all good there's a lot
of food in la
there's a ton of food
okay back to it you know i get a little
distracted but it's all good we're gonna
we're gonna keep going
so we have scatter one scatter two
scatter three
let's kind of take it back
take it back to scatter one and let's
get some of that dead stuff up in there
so i'll switch that out for this one
through
fourteen
sweet and i'll scale that stuff up
that's nice that's pretty nice
something pretty subtle
and maybe we try that in the the cracks
here
dude if that if that i don't know if
this ian is real or not but
if they if they just randomly
got the noodles question right that's
that's impressive
we'll see i i have no text from ian yet
i'll just text let me text him let me
see
all right the word's been sent out he's
a busy man i don't know if he'll get
this
but the text has been sent we're gonna
get verification here pretty soon
i know it would have been one heck of a
guess huh
all right let's see let's grab i'm just
you know this is just the stream today
y'all
we're just trying to make this stuff
look nice
spending those detail points
so i'll do an octane and a universal
material type
so that we can come up in here and we
can plug
the
let's see transmission yep that's right
it's got a transmission
section there and we can take the
specular down
just by half maybe and we can probably
take
the brightness up to two
maybe the saturation down a touch just
the touch
0.8 or something
see they seem too dark to me
so maybe we can take the gamma
down 0.7
let's grab some more of like the dead
stuff and let's put the dead stuff in
the corner
all right so let's see
we can't find this
so this stuff right here
hmm let's copy this
not copy it we'll drag it into scatter
number one the original scatter
boom
hey that looks pretty nice actually
i like that that feels dirty and kind of
gross and
overgrown i'm feeling that that's
looking sweet
nice okay and then the middle
let's have the middle section be a
combination of both of those
so i'll control drag that into scatter
2.
and let's grab all these other
variations i'll just
get these out of here
and then we'll do let's see scatter
one
yeah scatter one we'll grab those we'll
copy these
ctrl drag drop it into scatter 2 as well
dang did octane crash again
i think so shoot
but i think we can let's try and scale
these up because i know we're going to
scale these up anyway
before we reset everything i want to get
them about the same
the same size
yeah something like that
awesome we'll save that i'm gonna save
it as a new one actually
and we'll restart
yeah agreed a little bit of rocks some
some dirt small rocks
and i think it'll be looking nice
so i got a question for you guys would
you prefer i had music
playing this whole time or would you
prefer it's silent like it is so you can
play your own music
if you would prefer for me to have music
on the stream give me a thumbs up
if you would prefer to me if you would
prefer me to keep it as
is with with just silence so you can
play your own music give me thumbs down
let me know what you guys think
and i would love to do some polls on
this kind of stuff eventually
there's just a lot of business to do you
know a lot of business in the day
and let's render that
yeah i pro honestly i prefer the silence
that way you guys can actually
play your own music if you would choose
to because then you have an option you
know
ronan votes for the thumbs up with a
little bit of music but you know what i
mean it's like
without music you guys have the option
to play whatever you want
but you also have the option to keep it
silent too
if i have music then you can't stop the
music it's just like dude i'm getting
tired of this music
but i don't know i don't know
it's mixed i see i see it's mixed a lot
of thumbs downs though you guys enjoy
the silence i like
i like the silence too we don't have
enough silence in our life
constantly full of music and
talking and noise and all that good
stuff you know
it's nice to just chill out take a break
all right let's take everything in the
middle and scale it up
and let's also give it its own random
effector
i'm gonna make a new one
and we'll throw that down i'll get
random two out of there random three
will be for this one
and we want random three to have
the you know full 180 degrees of
rotation
we'll go 40 and 40 degrees dude
octane freaking crashed again oh my god
what the heck
that's so jacked
what is going on
like i have a i have plenty of room left
i don't understand why it's
freezing up on me like that
so weird
all right so this is it right now
if i throw in the safe frames
100 you guys can see what it'll look
like minus the floating plant
sweet let's see if we can't grab like a
pipe or something
um but we need the rocks we need the
scattered rocks and we need
maybe some dirt let's grab let's grab
some scattered rocks
uh 3d assets will go
nature rock
is there a scatter option yes there is
and we can find some
rocks small rock pack
that's easy
here's some sticks and rocks
some rubble scattered stuff could be
cool too
like concrete debris or something
small rocks pack this is the one i use
for my for my uh
car on the beach render
scatter granite rocks
scatter mossy rocks i like this one
let's download these
and we'll scatter these guys about bam
we just need the 2k versions and we'll
export those
all right c4d is thinking really hard
hopefully not crashing on me
i think i think qixel i think they have
poop
they just have a steaming pile of poop
they have horse poop yep
classic definitely want to
save that for later
oh come on c4d
dying on me what the hey
something's going on
why don't i use s24 man that's a good
question it's because i've been working
on this freaking
render for so long i don't want to
switch versions
in between um giant renders
so once this one's done i'll get started
on s24 also i think
i don't know if octane is out for s24
yet so
yeah gotta get my octane
all right let's see if we can get those
rocks up in here them scatter rocks
poop um let's do
3d assets nature
rock scatter
all the way to the bottom
the way to the bottom and we'll grab
this guy right here we'll export that
let me type in let me just see what they
have when i type in scatter
debris because i feel like there'd be a
lot of stuff
down there there'd be like sticks and
freaking tree sticks
there'd be trash there i feel like there
would definitely be some trash down
there some cans and
all that stuff some pipes maybe
but let's start with the rocks
and you know what i'm not even going to
scatter them
with the octane view right now because
i'm just going to look at it and
just make it work here we go rock pack
bam all these guys
um let's throw it in an octane scatter
and let's scatter it on
to the entire floor which is
where would you be the floor
yep octane scatter on
to the floor we want probably 200
rocks on the surface and you see all
these tiny little dots
those are all the little rocks so i'll
let that
do its thing and i'm going to organize
all this so we can clean it up a little
bit later so this is our
rock scatter
the scatter 2 is our
center scatter scatter one
is the crack
scatter and then we have
corner scatter
bam and i am going to
group all of this stuff into one
folder here let me also just
double check what the heck this stuff is
all right those are plants
boom
all right we can just let those chill
for a second
um anthony cavill yo thank you
thank you for the super chat i
appreciate you man you have a question
how do you decide if you want to
download a 2k
or 8k version of an asset and mega scans
i finally started my part
my participation by the way congrats on
starting
sometimes it's the hardest part is to
get started so
good job on that and that is a very good
question
how do you decide whether you download
um a
8k version or 2k version and how do you
decide if you want to export an 8k
version or 2k version so
basically here's the way i think of it
right now
um i have infinite hard drive space if
you guys are
really crunching on hard drive space i
would really recommend if you're doing
this as a 3d artist
invest in some hard drive space so
always download
the 8k version always download the
biggest version you can
um because you're future proofing
yourself you want to make sure that you
have
the highest res version if you need it
now when it comes to
exporting what you have downloaded
you can export the 8k version the
highest res version or you can export a
4k
or a 2k version the way i think of it is
there's a couple a couple couple things
so you want your render to look as
high-res as possible right
but you also want to balance
um performance at a certain point your
computer is going to explode
if you have too many 8k photo scans
in your scene so what i do
is ask myself um well by default
i'm kind of like exporting the lowest
res versions
so i'll export 2k versions 4k versions
of all these photo scans and all these
textures and assets
because it's going to be easier to go
back and replace the ones that are
closer to camera
with 8k versions then it's going to be
to like have to redo everything because
your computer's crashing because
everything's 8k
and you have to go back and like change
it all out again
so just start low and then work up
um to the 4k and the 8k versions once
you're kind of
looking at your full complete render i
would rather get all the way
to the end with a 2k
setup basically than to 20 percent or 30
percent
40 of all 8k and then it starts crashing
on me
then you have to kind of redo everything
so that's the way that's the way i think
with the rocks and the scatter i know
i'm going to leave that stuff 2k um i'm
trying to save as much computer juice as
possible with the rocks and the grass
and the scatter you're never going to
see that detail
but for the foreground elements the dirt
that is right up in your face
the like you know the train little train
wheel that's sitting right there or like
your rubble that's
right in the foreground i know that
stuff is going to be 8k eventually
so i'm downloading the 4k versions just
to get everything placed and once
i have everything locked in i'll start
switching them out for the ak versions
until my computer explodes then i'll
undo
one of those so that it's not exploding
and then i'll render it
hopefully that makes sense to you guys
all right so we have our rocks
scattered um there's going to be some
trash
let's let's get some trash going um i
know
let's see let's see trash
scatter hmm
so i want the actual 3d objects versus
these little like cards these are just
cards
so we could do trash and we'll look
in the 3d assets
and we'll scroll down and see what we
can find
this rusty container this rusted metal
can
this paint bucket
this is all good stuff
yeah rusty container
let's do it download the 4k export the
2k
same for the paint can let's actually
you know let's see let's see here we
have hmm
the rusted can
what is this metal containers
i like this it's like dirty oil canister
that's very nice i'm gonna download that
one but actually you know i think i got
the pack
so i might just work with that pack that
i have and scatter those around let's
get the can
you know you gotta you gotta get your
rusted uh can of beans
for sure up in the scene
we'll export the 2k
and if you guys have any computer
information if you guys are known
wanting to know what cards i have or
what ram sticks all that good stuff
it's in the description you guys just
drop down the description you can see
the stats my pc stats
all right and maybe a cigarette box
download the 4k
to future proof it in case you ever need
the 4k
and then export the 2k
because we don't need all that data up
in our scene you know what i mean
sweet how many points do i have left
i'm i'm probably riding it pretty close
i'm still good i'm still good all right
sweet okay
so we want to scatter some trash let me
see if i can't find
where would you be the
scattered trash
um scattered plastic bottles
all of these guys
yep all right i'm gonna control drag
these out
so we can use them bam
got a bunch of bottles here
oh you know be good with some tires man
yeah you need a couple like
nasty tires a pile of tires or something
but yeah we can get all of these i like
the yellow one
um let's see
the yellow one the
gray one here and maybe the
hmm yeah let's grab these guys
one two and three
awesome
sweet and i might actually like hand
place these but we'll see
um we got a couple
other things here we have
it's like a cigarette box
we got what is that that's the cigarette
box
this is our can of beans and this is our
random canister
and those are the rocks that we are
scattering currently
and i can move all of those rocks back
to our asset pile that's behind camera
same for the other stuff here
let's move all this stuff back
and out of frame
so i just want to go really easy with
this um and scatter these things
pretty strategically again i might have
to hand place this just because of the
size but let's at least get it
going
all right so i'm going to get the gizmo
oriented properly
on all of these pieces so that they're
sitting on the ground
and i'm using the axis center tool
to do exactly that so for this one i'll
probably flip it
on its side like this and
i'll re-orient the axis
with the axis tool over here and then
let's just go ahead and drop that down
to the bottom so it's going to be
sitting flush on the floor
this can these cans probably will not be
sitting upright so i'm going to actually
rotate them 90 and then
make sure i undo the gizmo so that's
sitting upright and then drop the y
down to the bottom same for this can
here
rotate it so it's sitting on its side
and we'll basically drop this down to
the bottom
sweet
this guy as well i'm just gonna copy
these three
and this white one as well and we'll do
the same deal we're gonna take
all of these we're gonna rotate
them let's go ahead and rotate these
guys
per object manipulation will check that
so they all rotate like this
90 degrees we will undo that gizmo so
they're all
just about the same and then with all
three selected we can
execute this function here so that the
gizmo
is right on the bottom there
cool so now when i take
all of these little trash pieces
here here and here
and we'll grab one two three four
basically all this stuff we're going to
scatter right
and i'm going to hold ctrl alt i'll drop
it into a scatter
and we're going to scatter it onto this
ground here
we want it on the surface we probably
want 20 of these tops
we don't want to overdo this and i will
select
the floor so that they are scattered
on the floor i'm also going to want to
randomly orient all these as well so
we can grab um these random modifiers
i think random two yeah random two let's
drop that onto the rock scatter
as well as the
trash scatter
and random two is just getting our
orientation
we can probably
ease up on this or nah we'll make our
own
i think we need to make our own
scatter for these now the trash scatter
yep that's working properly
we can get rid of the random the rock
scatter is going to be
fine as is trash scatter
let's go ahead and make a new one random
effector we'll drop that in there and
this random effector will not be a
position
one but will be a
orientation we can probably do like
three degrees on each one of those
that looks about right
mr sai sharon welcome welcome back
thank you again for the chat i
appreciate you man you missed the past
two hours
but it's good to see ya um i'm happy to
see you here as well
how was the climb dude it was sick man
yeah we went up to a place
um very very tall rock climbing wall
with a little bit of a slant to it
positive slant forward it was really
good to get back into it i've rock
climbed
a whole lot for years and years and
years
a few years ago but you know when the
pandemic hit and everything i actually
stopped climbing a little bit before
then
i used to go like to the gyms and stuff
here in la
um but yeah it was sick man
rope rope climbs are serious business
learning how to tie them in yourself too
is even more serious business so it was
a good time
very fun all right so we have a rocks
and we have our trash i think it's time
to hit render on this thing
tinum no real ian did not confirm yet
i don't think it was really ian though
i i don't i don't think it was really in
and there's a couple there's just a
couple things a couple reasons to why i
believe that but
until he hits me up i'll let y'all know
because if i go on about why it wasn't
really in he hits me up he says actually
yes it was i'd be like god dang it
how you guys doing everyone doing okay
thumbs ups if you guys are following
along
still enjoying the stream thank you guys
for hanging out with me
through all the crashes we got a lot of
crashes today
sweet thank you all good times
sweet
that's pretty nasty down there i'm a fan
oh snap bonsai
yo thank you that is very generous of
you
you say you've been a fan for 12 years
and you've been working with blender for
five months
and this challenge is the biggest one
you've worked on yet
and you're learning a lot dude that's
great thank you
thank you for that it's very generous of
you i appreciate you very much
and i'm glad that you're learning a lot
i know we all are we're all learning so
much on this thing and it's really cool
it's very very cool to see you guys um
learning as much as you can that's the
way to go
all right so i'm just trying to like
clean up the middle
i think the middle is a little too
spread out
so i believe it was a random three
that was getting us that spread
so we just kind of bring it in a little
closer together
and i'm going to take all of these
pieces here and make sure they're set to
rock scatter yeah all this stuff
all set to glossy and octane
sweet very nice
yeah you gotta have the tire in there
somewhere i don't think mega scans has
tires but i will double check
nah
maybe in time that's something i'll go
to cg trader
for let me reconnect these freaking
fence
textures here it's been long enough
um let's go ahead and do a little
organization
let's add this to the mega scans layer
we can delete those
um this will be
its new layer let's add this to a
new layer that's called uh cg
trader
and let's reconnect these guys i don't
know why sometimes
these textures just get lost when you
start up
c4d again but man it happens
metal fence pole all right let's find it
i have a video that i still need to edit
it's just going to take forever because
i interviewed basically
everyone i could i interviewed beeple
ian hubert um
blender guru andre lebrov a whole bunch
of people
almost a year ago asking them about
their techniques when it comes to
organizing their files
so i wanna i wanna finish that video for
you guys
because it's very very important um and
it's really important to work as
efficiently as possible the more time
you could spend creating
versus looking for files then you're
just going to be more efficient so
i want to finish that one it's just a
long edit
all right let's see if we can find our
3d models cg
trader uh date modified
yup chain link fence
and i believe that should load properly
sweet all right we got our chain link
fence going
so part of me kind of wants to have
this like
this concrete
wall this concrete sewer end similarly
to the way uh
this is ending here
like this where it just goes off
into a scary pit i kind of want
that vibe going
and i think it's going to work a little
bit better
than this hole in the background because
this hole in the background
isn't really selling as a hole in the
background
it's kind of just more so a
a wall it looks like a wall i'm not
really feeling it so
maybe i try and make this work here
maybe we see if we can't do like a
little
creepy tunnel system that just like gets
buried down
i'm gonna give it a shot
let's see what we can do here i'll
uncheck the check camera
octane's probably gonna crash again
but we'll do what we can now what i want
to do
here let's go ahead and take this floor
hmm what's the best way to do this
so i have these side walls here
both of these guys and i kind of want
them to continue
do a little bend modifier action on
these things
have them just kind of go into the
depths of the earth
all right how are we going to do this
simon how are we going to do this simon
thank you for the super chat simon it's
been five times
um and i tried to like the stream just
to realize i already did so i had no
choice
dude thank you thank you so much man i
appreciate you simon
heck yeah shout outs man shout out to
simon good times
have i ever used blender ariza
asks have i ever used blender apologies
if i got your name wrong
yeah i've used blender just a little bit
more so
to demonstrate things how things can be
done in other programs i've never
seriously used blender to create stuff
um c4d
that's that's the main love right now
it's you know i can't
i can't i can't do both right now i feel
like it would be it'd be bad to do both
not bad
it won't be bad to do both i've talked
about this before
it's the idea of using your left hand
versus your right hand
no hand is better than the other right
i'm right-handed because i've been using
my right hand for my whole life so i'm
gonna keep using my right hand
um you know if you're crazy for whatever
reason you're gonna say hey i'm gonna
challenge myself i'm using my left hand
only for the rest of my life
so then you'd switch to some other 3d
program that you
you know you're already a master no hey
hold on hold on
i'm no master all right i'm no c4d
master
i'm pretty good but i'm no master
i just know how to use the program
pretty well there's a lot of things i
don't know how to use
but i know it well enough right it's my
right hand it's my right it's the main
program
why would i switch to a program that i
don't know how to use
and handicap myself you know i would
rather switch to unreal engine
but i use the word switch to very
sparingly i don't want to say i switch
to unreal engine
i'm going to learn unreal engine because
unreal engine
i feel is a
it fills a hole it fills a gap in my 3d
workflow
that c4d cannot fulfill c40 cannot do
real-time
game style stuff um you can't make games
in c4d and you can't send out exe files
for people to play and have a good time
with so
yeah i'm gonna stick with c4d no real
reason for me
for me to switch to blender if i'm gonna
spend a ton of time learning something
new
i would rather that time be spent
learning something um
that fills a new hole you know like
spend the time learning
substance painter i would definitely do
that
rn tape what's the difference between
3ds max and blender or sorry
3ds max and c4d it's the same thing
basically man
3ds max is owned by autodesk
i think is the company and cinema 4d is
owned by
maxon they both do very similar things
c4d is just newer 3ds max that hasn't
had an update and i can't remember how
long i
i don't know maybe it's been updated and
i just forgot about it but
i used to use 3ds max for six years
actually
but i switched back to c4d because c4d
was the first 3d program i started in
the first real one rather
the first one was wings 3d that was the
first one i ever used
all right let's see if we can't get this
uh
this guy going off into the abyss here
so what i'll do is i'll take the floor
i'll ctrl drag it let's see yeah i'll
control drag it out
and flip it around whoa
180 degrees
and i'll control drag it up
flip it 180 degrees so it's a
tunnel situation going on here
and then let's grab these side walls
and let's see
grab the side both of the side walls
one and
[Music]
two
turn off this per object what's going on
here
i'm just let's see let's control
wall one wall two control drag it up and
out
so we can mess with it up here
i am going to
delete these polygons
delete these polygons i just want the
straight wall
and i'll center up the axis
bam while one wall two good to go
take those
and let's see
actually maybe before i center up the
axis bits
yeah i'll just move that down this way
we'll take the other wall we'll move
that down this way
and then i'm just going to use l and
center up those
those mid points there so now we have a
tunnel
situation going now i want to bend this
downwards essentially i want to bend
this downwards
um
and i want it to bend over kind of a
long period of time so hopefully a bend
modifier
will do the trick for us let me save
this
and grab these floor pieces
we'll drag these up and out just so we
can mess with them here
bam very nice okay
let's um let's make a new project file
and let's see if we can't make sense of
this bend modifier so i'm going to make
a plane
and we'll kind of replicate what we have
that's our floor
all right and let's um let's see if we
can get this bend modifier working it's
the first one right up in here
the bend modifier right at the top of
the stack
and let's set the strength to 90 degrees
we want a 90 degree bend
and we need to make the bend i believe
the parent no the child
perhaps the plane
you can see it's not bending properly
i've always had trouble
with the bend deformers
um dominic dude freaking awesome man
thank you for that really really nice of
you
uh you say you love the content and the
challenge your scene got very big
the render will take a week yeah dude
seriously my render is gonna take about
a week too
one question you want to change the arms
watch the tutorial but the arms always
snap back
um in the position in r23 yeah you just
want to make a keyframe you got to make
a starting keyframe
on those arms so that they can uh
you know remember where they were so
make sure you make that keyframe um for
the either the position the rotation
whatever you're trying to mess with
hopefully that should work for you
if not like send me a dm on on uh
on discord maybe we can't help you with
that
all right fit to parent let's see fits
the parents uh where'd the bend modifier
go
you said try rotating the bend
uh-huh but yeah it's not
[Music]
ah
okay bend modifier fit the parent
it totally disappears very strange
i don't i don't get the bend modifier i
don't get why
that works
so if i wanted to bend over a longer
period of time uh very interesting
angle uh-huh
i mean i guess that this could work
because technically we're not seeing it
but if i wanted to like
i guess i would just have to scale it up
i'd have to scale it all up
i'm wondering if i could do very
basically
this wall
90 degrees on that boom let's just
pretend like we have our little tunnel
system like this
and we group it all together we drop
that in
and yeah that totally works okay so
that's the answer
definitely the answer let's go back into
our render
let's group all that stuff together
we'll call this tunnel
and let's throw that bend modifier down
shall we so we'll make the bend modifier
we'll pop that in there and let's try
fit to parent
and we want 90 degrees
and we'll rotate that 90 degrees
the reason it looks wow the reason it
looks so bad
we need to scale this up
something like that and we also need
geometry on our floor
that's gonna help so what we can do is
just uh
hit kl for a loop cut
and make a cut and just add a whole
bunch
we'll do 15 cuts okay so that actually
goes down just like that and then we'll
do the same for
the ceiling
boom 15 cuts
or so
sweet now it's just darkness which is
creepy but i i want to be able to see
into that just a little bit more
same for the walls the walls need to
have a bit more
yeah just a bit more cuts in here so
we'll go one
i wonder if this will work nah okay
so we need to
and do this for every single one that's
crazy
cool not bad not bad same for the other
wall
just to a certain point
awesome
all right so yeah it's definitely a
creepy tunnel i'm kind of digging the
creepy tunnel vibe
more so than the the giant hole in the
background but i kind of want to make
this a little bit bigger
and i'm wondering if like we can cut
some holes in
the ceiling of this to give it a bit
more
light um
let's see we want the floor
yeah we want this guy and we'll cut like
some holes up in here
no that's not really helping we need we
need to see
the ceiling we need to see the drop and
i think the reason we're seeing it
in this render is just because so much
of it is in daylight
and is being bounced around
[Music]
yeah you want that gradual transition to
just a dark pit so
we can
i wonder if it's best to like
have this open up and get a little bit
larger as it goes back towards the
back here
hmm
yeah because this is certainly tapered
off
that this is the most terrifying thing
i've ever seen in my life though
could you imagine falling into that oh
my god
a fire drum yeah a fire drum would work
for sure
absolutely
yeah we could we could cheat right we
could cheat
make a light if
if octane and c4d wants to work that'd
be chill
it's frozen
dang what the heck
all right we ain't crashed let me try
one thing
all right we're in business so let's
yeah let's try making a light
and we could simply just illuminate this
tunnel a little bit
um we'll turn off visibility in the
light tag
way too intense way way too intense
and we could take this light down to
like 20 percent
yeah but i think what we need if we want
to get that effect
i don't think the light is going to help
us too much i mean we could
try to illuminate well if i if i undid
that we
brought the light back in you know we
could simply do something
like this if we wanted to pretend that
you know this tunnel system had
lights up on the ceiling and it was
going down
into it would be a move but i feel like
that would be not as creepy
as that reference image
so i can make an instance of this light
and start moving these guys back
and hoping that like the bounce light
will give us a little something but i
don't
know
it's also taking forever and a day to
render too so
not ideal
yeah i don't think that one's the move
either
the normals are correct
normals are certainly correct i think
it's just them
it's just how i have
the ceiling here so the ceiling
would essentially need
let's see let's see
all right we can take those and then we
can move them
uh soft selection radius
1000
and we'll set it to bell
now we want dome
or do we want bill 2000
so i switch back to linear and i'm just
kind of like peeling this back
little by little
yeah i would need a light
essentially coming from the other side
just too backlit i think that's the
thing
could also take up the brightness of
that texture too
claudio uh i appreciate the super chat
man
yeah i think the the normals are
probably fine
um they're certainly facing the right
way i know i need to get rid of this
water streak
on that uh on that texture there but
i think it's probably just a matter of
let's control drag this this is my
concrete
i need this guy let's add this to the
custom
thing here we'll duplicate it and we'll
make this a little bit brighter
so we can potentially take this
up to like 1.5
and we'll try that let's try that
it helps a little bit
i think it's just the angle too the
angle doesn't
really help um
it'd be it'd be better if we were like
right up in here you know what i mean
so you see like down into this pit just
a little bit
if the slope wasn't so steep
okay so if you're saying like just the
20 degree
or even 15 degrees
all right let me take the roof let's try
this again
let's bring this up control drag this
guy up
and we can take all of these
points ctrl a and hold shift
whoa
make sure they're all sitting flush
and maybe there's a way to have some
light
shining into that area somehow
it's a bit more natural
maybe it starts a little later the
ceiling part
let's push back a little bit
no that doesn't help that's just
that's interesting though
yeah i'll definitely mess with that and
see how that works
emissions alongside the rail
oh you know be interesting hmm maybe
like glow sticks or something
like people have gone down there
or like
maybe there's like maybe it's reversed
maybe there's just a really bright
light source coming from the bottom of
that tunnel
i don't know if that would look good
let's try it we're here to experiment
so what really works here is if i
actually select that light and i go to
cameras
and i use set active object as camera
i am now the light
so i can position the light based off of
you know where i'm at in the scene here
something like this maybe
and then that's obviously like
really blowing out so let me switch
back to active camera
and we can turn that light way down
um we can get up in here potentially and
open it up and then just turn it down
and i think i'm going to make a new
version of the texture so let me open up
photoshop real quick and do
a version without the
the water streak down the middle
all right so let's open up let's see
one of these is the one i need
all right not that one
ah nice okay so i i definitely i took
care of myself i have the version
already
amazing amazing amazing all right let's
uh control drag this out
this is the version without the water
because i added the water after the
and i'll just search for the bridge
version
and i'll set the specular to the correct
version as well
there we go and i'll apply that
to the ceiling
and maybe we'll tone down the
specular
the mix
the roughness is probably fine as is
and that light is not gonna be daylight
let's have it be warm light
mr flank cobra thank you
for that super chat much appreciated
support and love from lithuania very
cool i've never been
but you know i love to travel so that'd
be cool
uh do i need to rig my character before
changing the default one
or can i leave it boneless my character
will need more bones
for pistons and stuff i don't think you
can leave it
boneless and skinless you're gonna need
that full
on bony skinned uh
chicken breast if you want to apply
a new character if you follow my
tutorial there's like it's two videos
ago
i posted it last week and it's how to
take any 3d character and apply it to
any custom
3d rig any like custom mocap data
and basically what the way i know to do
it
there there are probably other ways to
do it let me just preface with that okay
but the way i know how to do it is to
you want to t pose both your skeleton
and the character you want to throw
on to the animated mesh
and t pose them like i'm assuming you
need bones to do that
i honestly don't know of any other way
but
if you find a way to do it let me know
i'm all ears i don't know
cinema 4d in its entirety you know i
probably know a good
30 40 of cinema 4d maybe 50
of cinema 4d other than that dude
there's so much stuff that i just don't
know
um so good luck with that uh i know it's
kind of a difficult thing
um to switch out the character there's
just a bunch of different programs that
people are in but
let me know hit me up on discord if uh
if you have a specific issue with that
flank
cobra but until then best of luck to you
thank you for the super chat
let's get back to it
greats for rain from above
would allow light to pass through
i like that
yeah very cool um there is a movie
called uh let me see if i can pull it up
for you guys
it's one of my favorites it's called
stalker
and there's a scene stalker um
there is a scene what is it stalker
sewer scene
that looks absolutely beautiful
of them just going through this sewer
like this
and you have these little light shafts
from above and
you can tell they're blasting the side
of this with a uh
with a light that's just off frame
but man does it look nice yeah see
they're hitting it with a light just off
frame to get this glare off the wall
but these little bits here are drooping
down
and getting you these nice little light
shafts inside here so maybe i'll do that
yeah this movie is beautiful have you
guys ever seen this movie
yeah this is this is oh
so good so good
um the cinematography in this movie
is top notch look at this
yeah if you guys hadn't seen stalker
definitely definitely check it out
uh it's a long movie it's very heady
it's a tarkovsky film um
but man is it beautiful
absolutely beautiful
all right so maybe that maybe that could
be a good way to do things
xavier yo dude thank you for the super
chat
you're wondering if your specs are good
enough for 3d
an i7 64 gigs of ram rtx 2080
yeah dude you're good i was rendering on
a 1070.
um about a year ago i was rendering on a
1070
and um 64 gigs of ram i think is what i
have currently
yeah dude you're good don't let your
computer stop you from
rendering cool stuff
all right
so
i like this vibe a lot i think it's a
really cool
vibe i think however
i think the way to get a little bit more
light into this tunnel
is to probably just
open it up a little bit
two times the size
two times the savings
um let's get this floor piece
looking right
um n c n
d and c yes the way to go let's select
all these
hit t for scale hold shift just get the
y
axis bam
actually you know what i'm not going to
do that i'm going to grab
just
just these ones out here
and i'll scale those ones down because i
still want a little bit of like drainage
central drainage piece there zero
percent
awesome we'll bring that up
cool and the walls themselves let's see
the walls will probably need to
be
scaled
um scale them up
scale them up
wow very interesting
that's really cool there's a lot of
depth in that you know
i might have it be the double sized wall
i like that a lot because that'll kind
of line up here with my
spherical element which is definitely
something to work on but
i like that that's really cool there's
like different levels
to the level you know what i mean
gradual curvature you think a little
bell shape to the floor
and probably the ceiling maybe the
ceiling
is straight up just a little hemisphere
so the ceiling
could do a little something
like we grab
this soft selection
circle and we go
i don't know 400 500
like that and we kind of
yeah do a little something like that
perhaps
and then throw the bend on it
ah i like i like it flat i think flat is
nice
and this could potentially be some sort
of road up here
a bridge yeah i like the idea of a road
being up here
that's really cool yeah i think i could
work with that and add a couple fun
little elements
to that you know
this light here could be very small
maybe tiny little light
just hitting the highlights of that so
maybe we can come into the specular
channel
give it a give it some contrast
not 200 that's a little intense
and we could bring this up
just peeking just peek in just a little
bit
move it back point it up to the ceiling
i feel like that's what you kind of need
you need like tilted up
towards the ceiling just off frame
that's a tough one
i want to spend a little bit more time
on that however
i do like this kind of setup with this
stuff going off
into the background i think that's
really fun really really nice
what we could do here is actually extend
this middle scatter area
and just kind of push that out a little
bit into the darkness
so we're scattering a little bit let's
see
that not the one
um center scatter yep
middle scatter that yeah i think that's
what we want
yeah so they just kind of the plants go
a little bit into
into that darkness just just a little
bit
sweet
ninja is listening while driving
be careful my friend be
careful thank you for the super chat man
that's awesome hope you were at a red
light
working great dude heck yeah
yeah it's looking really good dude it's
looking good we got a nice tunnel
system going and i can't wait to figure
out how to like
accentuate what is inside this tunnel
that'll be good
let's try that grading thing again maybe
we can figure that one out
maybe we select the roof
and we grab like this first little bit
we can delete it
let's see how do we want to do this
let's just extrude it no caps
bam and then delete the top
and we'll do this let's actually select
all the bits we want
first
extrude it delete it
bend it
ah interesting
i feel like you would need a little bit
of fog in there
to get some light shafts coming in let's
see
let's see about that let me just throw
on the fog real quick
i'll let that go for a second
these plants need to get out of here
all right um and then we still have some
more plants somehow
there we go
yeah the fog definitely adds
that is that is certain the fog adds
this render is going to be insane when
it's done
i can't wait
very nice yeah i think the shrubs up in
there look
really good i'm very happy with how
those turned out
and the reflection is looking really
nice too
yeah that's going to be good that's
going to be really nice
uh let me try changing the contrast
on the reflection for this guys let me
hit uh
boom 20 on the contrast
oh not for the
not for the actual texture
but for the specular let's try and get a
little bit more highlight and dry parts
out of it
sweet
yeah there we go you can see how like
it's a bit more wet and dry now
a little bit more contrast on that looks
really good
the light shaft's not a fan of yet
so i'll actually walk those back
sweet
it's starting to shape up you know
there's a lot a lot of little things we
got to do
but let's let's try and get some
graffiti on the wall maybe
i don't know if that'd be too much
um let's try it though so we got
it's going to be under decals and they
have graffiti they also have
leakage which is amazing
and i'm wondering if we can get any
leakage up in our scene
we might touch it up with some of that a
little bit later
but they got some good stuff concrete
leakage
but we want uh let's try graffiti let's
see what they got
[Music]
street boys fish boy
um
i don't want anything too cheesy and
cliche you know
i could also do my own graffiti too
that would be pretty sweet
hmm
yeah a warning message pointing towards
the
the tunnel could be sweet actually
i'll try this one for now
just as a test and we'll export the 2k
version
kombucha for life graffiti dude yeah
so this just gets i think scattered onto
a uh
or paste it onto a plane so we can
very easily make a plane drop that
onto the plane and we'll just have to
line the plane up with the wall
and that'll be that
so we'll just want to line this up as
close as possible
so it's sitting right on the wall we go
to like a top view or something
just to match it up as close as possible
that's very subtle yeah and then on the
right you can see there's a little bit
of graffiti action going on
but subtle is good i love me some subtle
and let's change this up let's do
glossy octane
and get it as close to the wall as
possible we don't want to drop shadow on
it
yeah there's still a little drop shadow
that's tough
this is really easy in unreal engine
but in c4d it just it is not easy
97.6
nah the other way 97.8
97.7
hmm
97 point uh i'm just trying to get as
flush as possible
point six five now the other way
seven five
is there a way to make it not cast a
shadow a great great question dude
um i think so
i think so yeah let's give it a let's
give it a test
so select a plane
pull it off the wall just a touch we can
see it's
got a shadow there if we right click it
we can give it an octane tag and
visibility will say
shadow visible uncheck it ah i thought
that would work
hmm so that's camera visible
shadow visible yeah
i'd have to make the wall shadow uh
uncheck shadow visibility on the wall
but i don't think that's gonna happen
that is close enough right there that is
darn close enough
sweet a compositing tag okay
um shift c
find our compositing tag let's try it
again let's bring it out
yep there's the shadow
and we can uncheck
cash out ah it doesn't work because it's
octane
probably because it's octane that's what
i'm assuming
why not just make the plane on that wall
with local axis and put the texture on
that plane
yeah that would be a way to do it for
sure
um but i mean i had it lined up
close enough that totally sells right
here
so i'll just leave that as is for now
yeah unreal engine makes it so simple
i wonder if there's something in c4d you
could do but
yeah i don't know
so i'm digging how this render it has
two versions of the render
there's like the first part and the
second part
first part's all muddy and gross and
destroyed and the second part reveals
this giant sewer
wait so you say that i can drag the
the material itself
onto the wall and it'll just work that
way
that's interesting once octane decides
to stop
or start here i will try that
yes redshift is a render engine so is
arnold
so is cycles and eevee those are all
render engines
and so is octane we have we officially
octane just crashed right now so let me
save
and we'll open it up one last time and
then i think we'll call it quits pretty
soon here
can i upload files to the chat
ah i can't i was gonna get i was gonna
try and give these to you guys
dang well soon there will be a place for
that i'll have a place where i can get
you guys all my materials and assets and
files and all that stuff
very soon
all right
so uh i guess in these last 10 minutes
here
i will answer any questions you guys
have if you want to at
me here in the live chat i will uh i'll
do that
i'll render the the image here kind of
give you guys a preview of what we did
but in the meantime
these last 10 minutes i'll just answer
some questions
because i'm hungry i'm hungry i hadn't
eaten today
thank you all for joining me on this
saturday i appreciate y'all
really every saturday you guys have been
here every single saturday
uh is this still the same render with
the circle shape white space in the sky
it is yes it is it is that same render
i'll be working on that
uh throughout this week and
um you know next saturday is the last
chance basically the last stream on this
render
and then we have to deliver on tuesday
june 1st
yeah what are my tips for photo realism
well i'd say
attention to detail is certainly one of
them
and it really depends on what you're
doing but be sure to include
surface imperfections that's a big thing
you know smudges on the glass
scratches wipes all that good stuff i
have a surface imperfection pack if you
guys want to check that out the link
is in the description on my gum road i
also have an hdri pack but that service
imperfection
pack is definitely something you guys
want to do
if you're trying to make things look
more photo real
a lot of first time 3d artists
they will just you know render the image
clean but there's a lot of things you
got to do to dirty it up
and that's really my favorite part so
service imperfections is huge for that
using an hdri uh
spherical environment to light your
scene helps with photorealism a whole
lot
um beveling your edges helps with
photorealism a lot
believe it or not um because there's no
such thing as a 90 degree perfectly
sharp edge in real life
everything every edge is beveled just a
little bit
um the attention to detail like the
grass
in the cracks on the sidewalk that kind
of stuff that will help your guys's
photorealism
so much i promise um
what else adding a little bit of camera
schmutz you know some grain maybe a
little smudge
maybe a little blur here and there
some bloom but it's very easy to go
overboard on that stuff so don't
don't go overboard on it it'll make your
render
a little bit of it will make your render
really nice and it'll blend in and it'll
look perfect
but too much of it will ruin your render
so
be careful with that stuff go easy on it
is there any way you guys can look at
the submissions right now no i am saving
the submissions
for uh two streams from now all right
once all the submissions are in
myself and a couple guest judges we're
going to
um basically show you guys all the
submissions live
and then we're going to come out with
the montage the following week
all right so i want to save those for
you guys um for
the montage video it's going to be
amazing and it'll be worth the wait i
promise
how did i get my name very good question
um
so when i was in middle school i got
together with a group of friends and we
used to just
you know goof off roughhouse and wrestle
and
uh you know we were fans of a show
called pure ownage
it's my favorite web series it is the
original web series i think it was like
the first web series
and it's about a group of socially
awkward gamers
um and it's the it's the best show ever
and the main character was the ponerer
and we all had in this little wrestling
group
you know it was just three of us goofing
off at my friend's house we all had
different names
so there was the grand master pwn there
uh there was the poner and then i was
the punisher so that's how
that's how i got my name because i love
pure ownage that show so much
what am i going to eat i'm going to get
some italian food
mr hallow dream a luxury yeah let me get
some italian food
[Music]
what else do we have let's scroll down
let's see what we got
is it okay to upload your own submission
to youtube yeah sure
i don't care you know i don't mind at
all
um
[Music]
i would probably yeah i'd probably wait
though
until the montage give me at least to
the montage
and like you guys are you guys are proud
of your work you know share your work
with your friends and stuff
but really it comes down to the montage
i'm going to pack them all together
and show show the world all the sweet
renders so
it'll be sweet it'll be really really
cool
um what else do we got
yeah i'm gonna keep doing challenges i
have a challenge planned for after
this challenge so you guys guys will
definitely be ready for that it's gonna
be a good one
i'll have news on that pretty soon um
after this challenge here yeah you guys
will you guys will feel it out it'll be
cool
hmm any tips for compositing the final
animation in
uh blender compositor i don't use
blender compositor i use after effects
so i don't have any blender compositor
tips but i do
have after effects composition tips and
that is to render out a z depth pass use
your z depth pass to comp in
smoke fire fog all that good stuff that
just takes up too much
computer juice uh in the render
so that's a good one don't forget your z
depth pass it'll definitely help you all
out
will every render be featured i think
what i'm going to do is do like a top
100
and then i'm going to do every single
render so there'll be two
essentially two render montages because
i want to show everyone's i would feel
bad if i didn't show everyone's but
everyone's together to be so long it's
going to be impossible to get custom
music written for it and i think the
best way to go is the top 100
and then basically everything
so i think that's the way we're going to
do it just depending on how many
submissions we get right now we're
already at 122 submissions
um probably more since uh
you know since we started this whole
thing
oh hold on we got a japanese comment
here what does this say uh
something oh uh
i don't that's not is that not
do i understand japanese a little bit i
don't know
i don't know i'm still learning i'm
still learning a little bit japanese
once a week for the last year and a half
yeah
but i think that's not i get gnaw and
saab mixed up
um but any you guys don't even know what
i'm talking about
i'm saying random stuff over here do i
have a tutorial on the node editor for
octane
you know i have a couple tutorials that
mess with the node editor
for texturing and stuff if you guys look
at the how to turn yourself into a robot
there's a whole texturing segment i do
on that i also have a tutorial called
my full vfx workflow and it's of like a
newspaper stand i go into
full texturing workflow on that as well
so i really
dive into the octane node
graph editor a little bit on those
he asked if i speak japanese hi
um uh let's see
sakoshi nihango
uh i get the order mixed up a little bit
ah
let's see hi um i'm speaking japanese on
the stream right now this is ridiculous
it's very fun i enjoy it a lot
and i hope to be very fluent one day you
know i'm
i'm listening to my japanese podcasts
um
let's see do i have a course in my plan
is there a course in the stars a
punisher course there will be
eventually but it's going to take a
while to make so
very busy right now and i think in time
maybe
end of this year beginning next year
i'll have a full-on vfx course or
something i know a lot of you guys have
been asking about that
um what languages do i speak just a
little bit of japanese
obviously i speak english i know a
little bit of spanish
just a little bit just barely um
so yeah i don't know i just love
i love japan man i've been obviously you
guys can't tell by the
freaking things over here um
i've been there twice i love the culture
i love the country so
it makes sense i i don't know maybe i'd
learn chinese next
if i had to pick another language to
learn but
what else do we have a couple more
questions i'm gonna bounce i gotta get
some food
um
[Music]
do i have a spotify playlist or two well
there's one linked in the description
and it may not be the playlist actually
it's like the early early streams
if you look in the description of the er
my earliest live streams
um like a year ago i'll have my
ambient music for vfx and reflection or
something like that
uh for editing and vfx in the
description of some of
my streams the early ones
so i'll have to probably um
i'll have to probably add that to these
descriptions because dang they are good
but i do have my favorite ambient artist
who just recently passed away a month
ago from kovit he was 27 years old that
sucks so much
we're gonna do a video together but i'm
still gonna do a little something for
him i'm gonna do a little
tribute tribute thing for mount shrine
so check out his music
um which japanese podcast dude i'm on
like easy
japanese it's like let's see what am i
doing
i'm doing the
[Music]
easy japanese it's called literally
called easy japanese
and then i'm doing a japanese podcast
for beginners
and those are the me oh and uh let's
learn japanese from small talk
those are the three that i'm listening
to every night falling asleep
i had my first dream in japanese
this week so that was pretty sweet i
want to get to that point where i'm just
like you know just consuming as much as
possible
um a couple more here
do you think 3d prop making will
eventually die out with scanning
getting more mainstream no
not at all because people still need to
create um like mesh
perfect props for video games
um until you can photo scan something
and have the mesh just be perfect then
i think custom uh modeling and all that
stuff will always be around
absolutely it's just really fun to do
too
it's really fun to make stuff you know
all right y'all my tummy is a grumbling
it has been a stream y'all thank you so
much for
hanging out with me guys i really
appreciate you guys
thank you so much let me show you what
we got just before i dip
this is the render this is the first
part of the render here
and we do a little scrolling over
and you get to let's see the second part
which is
the sewer system that we just did
very it's very widescreen very very
widescreen
so i still have a lot more work to do
seriously i got a lot of work to do this
week
i got the whole background to do but i
got a plan for the background i do have
a plan for the background
but y'all thank you so much for your
time
definitely um hang out on the discord
i'll be there this week
crunching on my render um good luck on
your guys's final submissions
if you're looking to submit definitely
hit up the discord the link is in the
description
there is an alternate realities uh
series of channels
and in the info channel you guys will
find a submission link you'll also find
a submission link
if you click on the little timer that's
counting down
you'll find that submission link as well
you only get one chance to submit
all right you get locked out after your
first submission because i
i can only handle so many files so make
sure you guys do it right
don't upload any works in progress
please don't do that
just need those finals but y'all
thank you so much have a good saturday
have a good weekend and i'll uh yeah
catch you guys on the discord server
next week is the final live stream
where you have like two or three more
days to finish your render all right so
that
you guys should have your renders near
final and if you guys
are looking to if it's going to take you
like a week to render then
plan for render time please do or use a
render farm
one of the two but thank you guys
have a good one i will see you soon
peace out y'all
later